by the way my private parts co-star the
most wonderful actor Paul Giamatti won
best performance by an actor in a motion
picture musical or comedy for the
holdovers yes he's fantastic in it right
after he received the award Paul
Giamatti gave be a shout out would you
ever want to work with Howard Stern
again and how would you think that would
be in a heartbeat I owe that man every
I'm not kidding I love that guy he says
he never wants he never wanted to act
after that again but if I could get him
back in a horror movie with with Howard
St that's a good idea I love him so iov
on
a what are they recording those
interview put a mic on him isn't it
amazing when somebody says something
positive about me you can't understand
it what the [__] finally like a major
actor for those of you who missed it
including me I think he said he'd work
with me again in a heartbeat I'll say
the horror movie had nothing to do with
you it was just specifically someone
asked him about horror movies before and
he was just sort of connecting so well
don't take here's the thing I will say
to be serious about Paul Gatti who by
the way owes me nothing he was great in
the movie private parts I did do the
majority of my scenes with Paul and at
the time because I was new to film
acting I didn't even realize how good
the guy was when I would watch the
scenes back I went oh my god look what
he's doing there he's so in the
character he's so good he made my job
easy like I I just remember doing scenes
with him and we didn't belabor them we
didn't do them like 900 times I didn't
know anything about acting so I didn't
realize it's because it was just done it
was like it was perfect it just he was
perfect in it yeah and I imagine this is
What actors good actors experience when
they work with one another it's as if
reality is playing out on the screen
happening yeah he was just a wonderful
moment in mind life so if I ever do
another movie boy I would want him in
it